what's going on you guys
lord addicts here coming at you with a
preview
today we're going to be playing dead h2
a little bit now
keep in mind this game is in its alpha
form it's not
complete yet this is not a
representation of the final build
but i really enjoyed this game when uh
we went to
pax east and i wanted to give the
audience a little bit of a detail
on what's going on with this game so
let's go and get straight into it
i already got a little bit of uh one
going on here
because because i played a little bit of
it because i don't want to look
dumb playing this game got had figure
out a little bit how to play it
so we're at night four pretty much what
we're doing right now
is we're just looking for supplies and
stuff this is the world map
alright so i already read this pretty
much all he's just saying is
at night the zombies are way more
aggressive so you want to be able
to safely search around for
supplies and stuff
and counter so this game's pretty much
turn base
there's three enemies here they're
they're pretty
slow actually to be honest with you now
what you want to do is i
i want to use a shotgun
and take out probably the brawler
so let's go and take out the brawler
real quick
that way he can't really do a whole lot
put him a defensive stance because he
doesn't have a weapon
and we'll just go ahead and he'll wait
he'll wait his turn
all right shotgun again
because it's best that we just go ahead
and kill that brawler there
ow so now what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and
take out that roller that way
these are a lot less aggressive than he
is
and plus you know we could defensive
strike these and they won't really do a
whole lot of damage
but we'll go ahead and switch rose with
him and start taking out
these people but since he has a shotgun
we're just going to shoot them
just doing a little bit of damage
there's quite a bit of them
but don't worry we still got this this
ain't nothing gonna happen wrong here
we're gonna still kill these zombies
zombies got nothing on us man
let's shotgun this one
found an old weapon part materials and
seeds
just keep going
if you notice the breeze stacked noise
running through your bag you find a
radio
jason can you hear me this confused for
a moment
we can talk like this sometimes when
it's advances advantages where
are you off today um
so we have a couple different options
here we could go to the city help a
companion or explore the area
let's just go to the city there's
something else i'm worried about the
zombie horde and other survivors are
looking
for help when you visit the independence
could you ask their leader
demise in there can they give any
support jack joseph
like to beg so apparently we need to go
find
a another group of people
oh there's a lot of people here what we
gonna do
let's do a scatter shot
i don't know if we should blade if we
should get closer yet
let's switch rows let's get a defensive
stance
do another scatter shot
i don't even know what that zombie threw
at me oh there's a
there's a crawler back there too
i said i don't think i'll need anything
like that yet but let's
let's do some damage
see now when you use that move what it
does is tosses them into this
into the row behind them and if there's
anyone behind them it'll do damage
74.
let's just shoot another one
let's go ahead and switch rows start
using a blade weapon a little bit
he's on fire i'm not really entirely
sure how to
how to put out the fire
oh my gosh man they're they're pretty
aggressive see this little skull thing
here that means he's gonna attack
with a strong weapon neck so we want to
take him out next
we don't want him to live at all
gotta take him out next
can't afford to be hit with that kind of
move right now
let's do a scatter shot
i wish i knew how to take put that fire
out
i love how he's just been on fire for
like 10 minutes
got it leveled up so just like i said
look it's definitely an rpg i really
i like games like this now we have shell
casings what you do with these is you
can go back to your base and make
actual ammo an old weapon part
bandages and we got some smugglers
noodles
you run into some civilians you see they
are carrying an item that might be used
to you
hand bandages so what i could pretty
much do it looks like is
i can negotiate with them or i could
just kill them
i don't know if threatening will kill
them let's threaten them
um maybe not maybe not
let's see if we could trade with them
you are offered one hand badges
want six scrap for it and you have to
scrap refuse
let's just move on let's let's let them
be you man let's let them be
we don't really need to do anything with
them right now
got some water we needed water
now we still got a little bit of health
left i think we're good let's go here
some blood everywhere
got some material needed some material
now what you use the material for
is use the material to build certain
stuff
at your base there's a lot of them here
man
that doctor is dead they all have really
low health though so i don't think it's
gonna be a huge issue
uh let's switch roll just go for a
defensive stance that way
she doesn't take damage next turn let's
do another scatter shot
now she's going she's going for it but
it's cool man because
that defensive stance really helps it
gets her where she can get close
in there that way next turn she can
attack
and then what i'll do is kill the doctor
let's just shoot this one
all right 75 now as you can see there's
a 75
that's the the chances of me actually
getting a
an actual shot i think this is one of
those games where it's not
you'll miss you just won't do you'll
graze them pretty much
man
zombies taking three shots that's that's
crazy
i'm gonna take protect the doctor you
know what let's do it again
let's do it again
you know what let's just switch let's
let's everyone have a turn everyone gets
a turn
but not you you're gonna shock on him
let's switch route oh she spit on me i
don't know how i feel about that
the spitting is is is too much man
it's a nurse
let's just keep on this nurse
leveled up
so we we found some hamburgers which who
made the hamburgers it's kind of weird
there's still a zombie over here it
looks like it's kind of weird that we
can kill it
uh bandage some share him
we just passed that zombie like we we we
we're acting like these zombies don't
exist
we actually needed some medicaids and
stuff all right so we got us a little
bit of
first aid stuff
all right
all right so
what do we want to do do we want to go
to the supermarket for food
now keep in mind here we're starting to
get a little low on health
i think we could do one more let's do
one more
there's another encounter
all right so i wonder how much ammo we
have
let's see
i don't think i don't think you have a
specific amount of ammo
i just think that you use that certain
type of ammo
all right so let's go ahead and scatter
shot the front line
let's go ahead and switch the row
oh the shotgun again man i like this
scatter shot
that nurse back there's annoying i'd
like to kill it
but right now we can't do anything until
we take out this front line
so let's switch back we'll go ahead and
just
focus her so she can do a little bit
more next turn
let's switch rows with him get a good
shot
oh he's got armor on okay
you have to have a cocktail to get these
people farmers on
as you can see it is destroyed whatever
armor he has
and there's a wolf okay okay wolves
could just randomly show that's awesome
man wolf's er look mean in this game
i'd actually actually let's oh man i
didn't mean to do that
all right so let's just do another
scatter shot
is he dead okay
let's do a little bit of bladed weapon
get bruce stock going on
let's get rid of him
uh we don't need any of that but let's
kill that cowboy
the cowgirl well let's
let's do dan let's do damage to her
let's attack that category again let's
do it again
let's go man how are you grazing so much
man
how you miss a zombie
there you go all right let's let's kill
this
nurse
nurse gotta go all right so
we found an old weapon parts found
material
and fabric not bad not bad man
it's definitely worth the effort
you find an unconscious civil you might
be able to help
let's try to help her
sixty percent try to help her man
you been down to help her when suddenly
she jumps up and yells
for reinforcements oh the trick never
gets old get him men
take everything man i hate looters
but we about to we about to mess up
these looters though man we we can't let
that kind of behavior go
unnoticed so let's go and switch the row
let's let's jack this chick up that uh
she definitely did us dirty let's go
into defensive stance
this is the last thing i'll be i'll be
able to do to be honest with you guys
um
he's got 277 health i think he'll be
fine i don't know how much damage
that gun right there does but he's got a
gun too
but let's just shoot this woman
because she's the reason we're in this
mess so let's kill her
oh through smoke grenade the damage to
everyone let's see how much these guns
do
i wonder if they have any like type of
armor on there but they're level
six we're level two
this this ain't looking good you guys
this ain't looking good
see that's what what happens when i try
to be nice to someone man that's what
happens
let's see who's got the lowest health
but these people got
guns so they got armor on
let's let's see what that does yeah
let's
shotgun let's try to get this huntress
uh out of here man we gotta get
one of these out of here oh my god
they're doing some serious they got a
dog
that's a very detailed dog congrats the
dog actually looks really nice
let's do a bladed thrust to hit that one
in the back
i got i got to kill the dog first it
looks like
now let's do a penetrating shot
let's do another one another slug
we got to get rid of these people with
the guns man
this chick here is she's hurting i got a
hill
maybe i can get lucky nope no luck here
man
oh
how how many times you gonna let the
shoe
all right so he's hurt
i'm going to have to throw medicine out
i can't
have them die man i can't have them die
we got to get rid of this huntress
she needs what does the most
let's just give her that i'm not trying
to have her die
let's give her that too i'm not trying
to have her die
let's shock on this dude because he
keeps throwing those smoke grenades or
whatever they are
they're really doing some damage
yeah look at that man
nah i'm hitting you you done
all right so now we only got one dude
with the shotgun
she doesn't have a whole lot of health
so i'm gonna have to hillary i'm gonna
switch rose
i'm gonna do a penetration shot
why does it keep missing that was a 70
chance of hitting
oh
all right so she she's out and about
she's dazed
oh my gosh kill her thank you
got some money alright so apparently
they do use money in this world
oh i didn't i couldn't really afford to
fight some zombies man
oh that ain't good
that's just not goods i don't know what
that
is about but
oh my gosh defensive stance
let's take out i mean we could take out
both of these no let's take that out we
know we could take him out
oh my gosh animations are pretty good
for this game it's a nice little rpg man
there's another one
let's switch the row
start taking out some of these people
hopefully
oh no it's looking pretty spooky man
it's looking pretty spooky
um
switch the roll let's kill this dude
can i not reach that crawler
shotgun scattershot group strength
that didn't seem right
man i'm really getting hurt
let's kill that brute there we go
grazed oh my gosh
alright so homeboy there is almost dead
why did not do any damage
thank you
all right we gotta go back to the house
we can't keep doing this we found some
food though we need the food and some
materials
so let's go ahead and go back to the
house
let's go back to base
we're done for the night you guys we're
done for the night